hey guys it's Justine and today I'm
gonna show you one of my most favorite
pieces of tech that I've been using over
the past couple of months and this thing
has completely honestly actually changed
my life huge thank you to Bravo for
sponsoring this video they have been so
incredibly supportive of me my channel
and even vlog university they gave us a
few bravas to give out to some of the
attendees so not only is the oven
incredible but their entire company has
been so generous and so thoughtful and
just very supportive of me and my
community so for the past few years I've
been focusing a lot on my health my
fitness and sort of just general
all-around well-being the one thing that
I noticed is I wasn't really seeing the
results that I wanted and unfortunately
I had to tell myself Justine it is the
foods that you're eating my day to day
was either eating out or frozen food or
ordering deliveries last year Bravo
reached out and wanted me to check out
this oven and I was extremely excited
because it was one of the most
technologically advanced things that I
had seen and obviously being a
technology lover and someone who can't
cook this is something that I felt was
right up my alley and I couldn't wait to
try it out it cooks in the combination
of visible and infrared light so this
allows the food to cook faster and more
efficiently than most ovens or
microwaves there's six high-powered
lamps to turn off and on in between
cooking and can focus on specific zones
in the oven without heating the area
around it so this allows you to cook
multiple items at the same time on the
same plate and those would normally have
to be cooked separately it has eight
temperature sensors two particle
detectors and one of my favorite things
a camera you can watch your food cook
without ever even having to open the
oven and it connects to an app you could
be watching your food live on your phone
while it cooks you want to pause it cook
you can control it on your phone it
connects to Wi-Fi so it will do updates
over the air you can get recipe updates
software updates and it's always so
exciting when I come downstairs and I
realize that there are some new recipes
added they work specifically with Brava
chefs she designed these recipes so that
you can do multiple cooks on the same
pan the app has a bunch of different
recipes built in so it'll show you
exactly what you need to make that
recipe so sometimes I will go through
the app find a really cool recipe get
all of the ingredients and I'll feel
like an actual chef because I will pull
off this incredible meal and really I
didn't do anything I just put some stuff
on some pans where it told me to put
them and the
and does the rest but now I want to take
you into my food vlog here we go
good morning it's time for breakfast
normally I actually eat 2 breakfasts
mostly if I go to an early gym class or
jujitsu or something like that I tried
to eat something very small before I go
to class maybe some fruit or some
oatmeal and then I come back and I have
a second breakfast which is usually a
breakfast sandwich or a breakfast
frittata usually something containing
eggs for protein so today we're gonna
make one of my favourite little
breakfast sandwiches it's actually an
open-faced breakfast sandwich but in the
Bravo menu selection I just choose
breakfast sandwich and we take it from
there
when I first arted using this oven I
followed the recipes exactly and as you
kind of learn the temperament of this
oven you'll figure out different ways to
change things up and make it your own
one of my favorite things about the oven
is there's so many different pans for it
so we have a square pan this is the
muffington loaf pan and glass tray for
my breakfast sandwich I'm gonna need two
of these pans this is the egg tray and
this is the metal tray this one is my
favorite because I eat eggs almost every
single day but you can use this to make
all sorts of different things I even saw
they had a brownie recipe which looked
incredible I didn't try it but I'm
tempted beginin has a temperature sensor
this plugs right is the oven so this
helps you get an accurate read of
whatever it is that you're cooking if
it's a fish or a meat so that'll be a
perfect temperature when it comes out
for you to eat so got our eggs and an
English muffin and I like to put a half
slice of Jack cheese on each piece
that's actually a half slice but a half
of a half the cheese will melt in the
oven and the muffin will be toasted at
the same time and
[Music]
since this is something that I cook
often I usually just go into recents
click egg and cheese breakfast sandwich
determine how many I'm going to be
making even though I'm making one I'm
using two eggs he tells me exactly where
to place the bread exactly where to
place the eggs if you want to adjust
your time I like a little bit running of
an egg so I decreased it by six percent
one last check before you're ready to go
and that's it time to cook my favorite
part about this is the fact that this
oven has a camera inside of it so what I
do a lot of times is I will make my
sandwich I will go up and take a shower
really quick and I will keep with a live
camera open to see how much time I have
left but I can keep showering and get
down here and just enough time for my
sandwich to be done it's done it also
gives you an option if I want to touch
up the cook but this looks pretty good
to me
oh I mean these are perfection I like to
add a little salt and pepper and then
these are good to go
it's going to be an open-faced sandwich
[Music]
it was so perfect breakfast is my
favorite part of the day
that's why I usually eat breakfast twice
and now I'm gonna make some blueberry
muffins to have as a snack throughout
the week I'm gonna change this recipe up
a little bit from what is on the Bravo
app I have made this recipe on the Bravo
one and it was so incredible but I want
to add some oatmeal so hopefully it
still turns out okay that's one of the
fun things that I love about the Bravo
Oven is I will kind of follow these
recipes and then you can change it up a
little bit to make it your own so
fingers crossed that this little works
[Music]
batter is made and only cupcake liners
that I can find were 'some from
Halloween since I don't really do baking
videos haven't even ordered remember
when I said I was making blueberry
muffins and I forgot to put the
blueberries in
[Music]
so we're now rapidly preheating the oven
and one of the things that I love about
this as opposed to regular baking it
preheats really quickly and it doesn't
emit a lot of heat from the actual oven
itself these looks so good I can't wait
to try them muffins are done how are
they looking
let's see I'm so excited it's always so
nerve-racking when you change up a
recipe because you don't know what's
gonna happen but I'm already super happy
with this these are pretty healthy
they're basically just like oatmeal
honey flower this is still warm too look
at that oh yeah I need to get a fork so
for this recipe I didn't use any sugar
to sweeten it I used honey so it's
definitely less sweet than a normal
blueberry muffin but it still is really
good it tastes like health
I need a testimonial from you
how were the blueberry muffins that I
made no way show me this wasn't an
implant gosh that looks so good well
enjoy your breakfast I'm gonna just keep
editing my video here this time for
lunch and Jenna brought over one of her
favorite things to make in the braava
oven frozen a sweet potato fries
absolutely favorite so I'm making myself
some salmon and vegetables and salad and
Jenna doesn't eat meat so she's
basically gonna show us her favorite
lunch and then I'll show you my favorite
lunch so Jen prep your sweet potato why
I eat other things this is just like my
favorite like little snack these looks
so good okay what type of pan are we
gonna need just wash this so they're
just a setting in here yeah make it
search for sweet potato fries roasted
sweet potato fries yep that's it wrinkle
or straight what do we have in straight
well Jennifer getting her fries ready a
prep I'm gonna get my stand already
[Music]
would you like to do the honors yeah
yours is blue you can change the color
no yep way yep in the settings yeah here
it turned blue Jenna they're done yes oh
man I'm taste test for you Oh Joel what
did your fantastic oh yes always thank
you you can take some
[Music]
okay we've sent two salmon to my oven so
you guys can see right here click it and
now we're gonna go through we've got two
fillets and now this is telling me to
enter the thickness this is actually a
measurer so let's measure our salmon and
then on here is a little graphic it
coincides and the height plugging it
into our meat first salmon goes into the
bottom shelf and then we plug in come
put your sensor right here to the side
[Music]
get on let's get on
look at you guys
the Faculty of this temperature sensor
will know exactly the proper cook and
there we go oh we got salmon is my
favorite oh yeah oh man I can't wait for
dinner time for dinner
I love dinner it's one of my favorites
other than breakfast and lunch of course
those are also my favorites I just like
food so for dinner I'm gonna make
chicken and cauliflower this recipe
actually has broccoli but it works
exactly the same so this is usually what
I use when I'm making a chicken and
cauliflower so I'm just gonna go through
and follow this recipe this takes about
16 minutes to whole time
my favorite feature is being able to
just send to this recipe right to my
oven so I click that little paper
airplane sends to the braava and it
shows up and this shows you exactly
where everything should be aligned and
it tells me which shelf to put it in and
there I got my notification that my
chicken thighs boneless and skinless and
broccoli has started if I click it it
will launch up the live stream this will
give me just enough time to prep a salad
[Music]
and here it is dinner is served
check that chicken out Maddie you can't
have any chicken because you're allergic
oh these are cooked perfectly oh my gosh
Oh like they also have a really awesome
community so on their Facebook page
people share custom cooks that they
created you can choose ones that you
like and then you could just download
them right to your oven so that vlog was
kind of an example of what I eat
throughout the day when I'm at home
working I also do snack a lot throughout
the day but it's usually on healthy
snacks I'm always looking for some added
protein so I'll have a protein bar
there's also these really good peanut
butter protein bars that I eat a lot of
sometimes I'll just go for a couple
scoops of peanut butter almonds cashews
oatmeal bars whatever fruit I might have
in the fridge I love bananas blueberries
strawberries thank you again for
watching I'll put a link in the
description if you wanna check out more
information about the braava oven and I
will see you guys in my next video
you
[Music]